hi I'm Kevin hi I'm Jackie and today
we're drawing more spongebob characters
for a memory today
[Music]
I know I grew up without television so I
don't know I know what spongebob looks
like Jason what shape is I don't know
you did such a great job with Patrick
Patrick is like one shape and Squidward
is like four shapes what four names is
he circle right maybe like a triangle
okay
mayhaps a pentagon they have it's
interesting I don't watch the show at
all but I is no way not to know what
this guy looks like I think I've drawn
this character so many times in my youth
it should be have you done research you
know what I have watched a little bit of
Spongebob how did you like it
I liked it a lot Oh can you tell me a
little bit about her so mrs. puff is
SpongeBob's driving instructor and she's
at wit's end with him because he has
failed whose driving tests like really
his head is quite large thing is that he
has a really big nose like that's right
in it tangle yeah it's like over his
mouth yeah he's got lots of tentacles oh
yeah he's got like he doesn't have human
hands don't draw human hands okay that's
gonna really freak people out think of
like a cereal box kind of like that
shape he's got like wavy lines on the
outside and then just give him some like
Swiss cheese holes his limbs are kind of
to be he's got like the rubber hose
thing going on I will never get tired of
spongebob it's just like it is ingrained
into our culture into some people's
culture and he's got like big eyes like
spongebob right yeah he's got a big old
nose I'm about much I think that's the
only thing I know about him
does he have gloves no no no because
he's yellow okay so his hands already
stand out the shape of his head mm-hmm
is it like a bullet shape or is it
something
different it's like a mushroom it's like
a mushroom imagine a mushroom you know
it's like a bulbous uh-huh and then it's
got the stem okay next question yes
is he wearing clothes yes he sure is
like shirt and pants what do you think
oh no oh this is the limit of you
helping me here it looks like a cookie
wait can I ask you for in hints are her
fins like hands or are they just like
fin
they're like fin feel big buck teeth all
right I think yes Bugsy's not wrong I'm
at okay oh now right now I got it okay I
think I got it now so I've made an
executive decision I am giving him both
a shirt and pants sounds good I'd
support you I feels no you're right keep
it go now I think you're effing with me
no I'm not I would never do such a thing
I'm actually like really cool and
awesome and kind it makes something a
sailor's dress is a very good reference
day when they had uniforms that are
inspired by like sailors yeah okay okay
does she wear shoes
yes are they fabulous yeah they're like
little high heels I think cute she is
really tiny like it's like an
interesting take on a Blowfish which is
cool
like I don't really think I've seen any
other Blowfish designs like hers how old
is she she's like middle aged does she
wear makeup yes I'm so boy okay oh boy
you should maybe restart the clock oh my
god I spent too long on the niceness of
the loins I think and you know
be able to color it I have to decide
what colors I want to make him he's a
very drab color I know that you should
try all sorts of colors
now you're just actively trying to screw
with me even you know find space for
this hi Jason do not forget the time
alright I won't forget I'm gonna come at
you in the comments the time I should
have formatted my drawing like one of
those drawing tutorials where it's like
just draw a square and I'll be like
listening to you
dropping it yeah next time who needs art
school when you can watch BuzzFeed
videos oh wait wait but does she does
she have arms yes well even though like
arm fins
you could take any frame of Spongebob
out of context and probably make a meme
out of it just because there's so much
like character and expression in it
sponge NAR or like caveman spongebob
it's like when future spongebob goes to
the past and like meets is like caveman
counterpart Wow and sponge gnar is like
Oh what about you Jason you got a
favorite spongebob me no I don't know
about the names much sigh audience I
live in the cave don't do that
oh my god can we have a loose - no
doesn't look right I'm coloring in his
pants and I feel like I made a bad
decision it's too late to change it it's
too late to change it you got a Camilo I
gotta live with it but I feel like it
was wrong for me yeah oh this is
definitely not missus I think I did
really well I think this looks like the
character more than anything else I've
done in this challenge you know what I'm
confident yeah I'm confident in my
decisions I feel someone okay I feel
like the pants were the wrong thing to
do we're gonna find out
he doesn't have pants oh they
oh she is so cute like that is adorable
you made her look like a Sailor Scout
she's adorable
did I kill it you did amazing I killed
him with a knife no I'm the real knife I
stabbed him over and over until he bled
misunderstanding me what until he died
no yes he's like robbing us at lighting
your finger point yeah this looks kind
of like the first draft okay before they
refined it yeah they were like they drew
this and they were like this is the guy
and then and then they like quietly gave
it to a real character designer and
they're like I think it's not bad drawer
they're like listen can you clean this
up for Ted here oh yeah exactly that I
forgot he had like the blue eyes oh yeah
oh and socks I didn't know you had socks
Wow I thought his holes were more 3d ish
you seriously like gave him like divots
into his like skin yeah you did it
you made my gritty live-action remake
Bob Oh would you look at that Wow
I mean you were dead-on was that yeah it
is like he has darker suckers small
circles are darker but you got the
purple you didn't give him a collar on
his shirt I was gonna say that you got
the collared shirt for some reason
that's a weird thing for me for you to
remember right she's a lot more hair
than I remembered yeah she does have
spikes
I shouldn't we got the legs right oh you
got them perfect don't know how you got
the colors yeah spongebob is literally
you've kind of like Mickey Mouse at this
point I don't know who the rest of the
characters of the show is but there's no
way you can avoid knowing oh yeah yeah
you're SpongeBob's gonna beat up my son
you did good Kevin thank you jack I'm so
sorry I never hope
you but I really like not helping you
that's weird but I'll take it I just
think it's funny it's just a good time
to watch you struggle please everyone
likes to watch me struggle I'm sorry I
told you that that's alright I'm just
gonna listen to you anymore
[Music]